all right happening right now a  barricade incident near dean martin and  blue diamond here in las vegas close to  the silverton casino  we have a live picture from our fast  camera right now police say  officers located a stolen vehicle that  thief  tried to take off in the car but then  ran off into a hotel room  the roads nearby there are blocked off  so avoid the area  you can see on the left side of the  screen there a couple police cars and  some law enforcement officers on the  ground you can't really see a lot  because it's a little obstructed but  they are asking you to avoid the area if  you can so you don't get delayed  that is also developing we'll bring you  the very latest as soon as we get any  updates